In Japanese what Maria is saying roughly translates to (see above):
This double entendre actually refers
to the corpse at the end of the Fishing Hamlet here.
While both the English and the Japanese do imply this, the Japanese translation
is way more overt about it by saying "corpse fishing".
This is just one of many examples of meaning lost in translation.
Because when the text and dialogue in Bloodborne was translated to English
certain changes would've been made by the localization team
to make sure that the text was palatable to an English speaking audience.
They've done a good job, for the most part, but in a game like Bloodborne
even the slightest translation that's not literal can effect our interpretation.
We found the best example of this in the Old Hunter's Bone description:
"The bone of an old hunter whose name is lost.
It is said that 'HE' was an apprentice to old Gehrman,
and a practitioner of the art of Quickening, which is a technique particular to the First Hunters."
What's weird is that in the Japanese description, there is no
reference to this bone belonging to a man, so it could belong to a woman as well.
And I can think of a more likely candidate, can't you?
This bone lies upon the grave that transports us to the Hunter's Nightmare,
which is a Nightmare full of old Hunters who possess this same art of Quickening
that the bone grants our hunter.
So, sure, it could belong to any of the old Hunters, man or woman,
but it just makes so much more sense if this belongs to Maria.
She's linked to this grave very heavily.
She was an apprentice to Gehrman's Workshop, she possesses the art of Quickening,
Gehrman had an affection for Maria, he even created the doll in her image,
the doll prays at this grave, and it's the only grave to lie just outside Gehrman's abandoned workshop.
So, after looking at the Japanese description, I feel very confident in saying
that Maria is the most likely candidate for this grave.
Assuming this is right, we can take this assumption further.
This grave exists in the waking world, meaning that Maria must have died
before Gehrman's Hunter's Dream began.
And this fact helps us put together a timeline and tell a story.
Perhaps laying Maria to rest here inspired Gehrman's meeting
with the Moon Presence and his subsequent escape into a dream
where he created something in Maria's image.
And it doesn't even matter if this is speculation because,
even if you don't agree, my point is that this is a line of speculation that we couldn't
even go down because the English translation said the grave belonged to a man.
And that's what this video is about. It's about combing through significant item descriptions to make sure we
haven't missed anything important, or to make sure we haven't been interpreting something wrong this whole time.
So, if you're like me, and you care about documenting this stuff, then listen along.
Also, let's get some love for the guy who made this video possible.
He goes by the name Loremaster Nojah (check description for link).
He's the one who hunted down the descriptions that
I thought would most benefit us being translated.
His initiative, his dedication, and his knowledge of the language is the basis of this video.
Let's do something cool for the guy and help him get his YouTube channel off the ground.
He's got these plans to create a play through of Souls games
focusing on translations and the lore, so subscribe to him if that sounds interesting.
Alright, so back to the translations.
This gender discrepancy with the Old Hunter's Bone got me thinking,
'What if other English Translations have misrepresented a gender?'
I immediately thought of Alfred's dialogue where he says this:
"Once, a scholar betrayed his fellows at Byrgenwerth and brought forbidden blood
back with him to Cainhurst Castle.
It was there that the first of the inhuman Vilebloods was born.
The Vilebloods are fiendish creatures who threaten the purity of the Church's blood healing."
Lo and behold, it turns out that this betrayer isn't necessarily a 'HE' either.
In Japanese this betrayer is referred to with a gender-neutral expression.
Which, obviously again,  opens him up to being a man or a woman.
And who this betrayer is has always been a bit of a mystery.
We don't even know if this betrayer is represented in-game.
Before this video, most people thought that it was the Cainhurst Crow who
appears in the Grand Cathedral since he uses the Old Hunter's Bone, which links him to the workshop,
and he also dons the Cainhurst Mask which links him to Cainhurst.
So it's possible that he betrayed the Byrgenwerth scholars and took
that forbidden blood to Cainhurst to begin the Vileblood line.
But now that the betrayer position is opened up to the female cast of Bloodborne,
the only candidate I can think of is Maria, again, but I'm
open to your ideas on this one since this is still speculation.
Maria is related to the Vileblood Queen so she has links to Cainhurst and she clearly
has links to the Byrgenwerth scholars because she was an apprentice to Gehrman,
and she ended up in the Hunter's Nightmare.
Plus, she resents what the Hunters did in the Fishing Hamlet, which could have inspired
her to betray the Byrgenwerth scholars.
But, again, there is nothing explicitly linking her to stealing Cainhurst's blood,
so what I'm saying is kind of a long shot.
Anyway, again, my point is that this long shot wouldn't even be possible unless we discovered this mistranslation.
And it is worth pointing out that we don't know how  much contact the English translation team
had to clarify questions of gender like this, so, bear that in mind.
The betrayer is potentially referenced in the Japanese version of Laurence and Willem's cutscene.
In Japanese the pronoun 'kimi' and the particle 'mo' can mean "you also".
So we knew there was a split from Byrgenwerth and now we learn that they may have split
before Laurence, not just after.
What I also found interesting was these lines in Japanese which say (see above):
The notion of "surpassing humanity (by the blood)" is largely missing from the English quote.
Furthermore, the adage of Byrgenwerth says: "We urge you to fear the blood (as you proceed)",
Where the English simply says "To fear the blood".
Speaking of fear, the Harrowed Set explains a little bit more about why the general populace
fear and hate the Hunters.
In Japanese the Harrowed Set is actually "The Disguise Set".
Worn by Hunters whose job it is to blend in with the populace and who have the power to act and kill
anyone they suspect of being a beast.
The English line:
Becomes (translated from Japanese):
The next line in English:
The final line in English:
Becomes (translated from Japanese):
And the implication here is that these Hunters had the Church-pardoned right
to kill where ever they see fit, to investigate whomever they want.
The English description posits them as the first line of defense against the outbreak,
Hunters who sometimes see Beasthood where it doesn't exist,
but the Japanese description suggests that these Hunters act with impunity,
uncovering the secrets of the populace all under the pretense of beast hunting.
And it does a lot to explain the paranoia of the populace, their fear of the church, and hatred of the Hunters.
Another armor set title that wasn't replicated perfectly is the Tomb Prospector set.
In Japanese, this name is actually a combination of the word 'tomb' and 'a thing that is rough or violent'
or 'a thing that breaks open'.
Nojah tells us that a direct translation would be "Tomb Break Opener", contrasting
with "Tomb Prospector" which sounds really gentle and scholarly by comparison.
We know from the way that the scholars treated the Fishing Hamlet that the scholars
weren't particularly gentle with this ancient race of alien beings, and the Tomb Prospectors were no exception.
In fact, they're downright rude in their naming of some Great Ones.
'Rom, The Vacuous Spider' is actually 'Rom, The Stupid Spider'.
The Japanese word 'hakuchi' means 'stupid or idiotic', and Nojah
says that these are the words you use when you call someone a 'retard' or something.
It carries that same social weight.
I feel sorry for Rom now, damn.
Rom is referenced by a few notes as somehow hiding rituals.
When we kill him, in fact, Mensis and their ritual are revealed to us and we can enter their nightmare
and supposedly interrupt it.
Since Rom is within a great lake, it reminded me of the Arcane Lake rune.
Here's its description:
"Great volumes of water serve as a bulwark guarding sleep".
The Japanese clarifies that 'guarding sleep' means 'preventing the sleep from being interrupted'.
Which I found fitting because great bodies of water do prevent nightmares from being interrupted.
Killing Rom in his giant lake allows us to interrupt the Mensis ritual, for example.
The great body of water over the Nightmare of Yharnam also guards
the source of the nightmare in the Fishing Hamlet preventing us from interrupting it.
And speaking of Rom, did you ever notice that his corpse, or a corpse of a being like him,
makes up the altar in front of Ebrietas?
This is named the Altar of Despair in English, but in Japanese it's actually the
Altar of Grief or Altar of Lamentations.
And from the way Ebrietas is positioned when we first enter, not even aggroing until you hit her,
we can surmise that this is an altar for her grief and her lamentations which, in my mind,
sounds a little bit more personal than the Altar of Despair.
I assume she's despairing because Rom, or this creature, has ascended without her
since she is referenced as 'The Left Behind Great One'.
Of all the information we do need, we need more information on the nature of the Great Ones.
For that, we should look a little bit closer at the Umbilical Cords.
It's very likely that these cords are needed to meet with the Great Ones.
Worth noting is that Mensis's Cord says "it granted them audience with Mergo" in English,
but in Japanese it clarifies that it didn't grant them an audience.
Rather, it's described as (see above):
Similarly, a note in the Lecture Building says, in English, the nameless Moon Presence
was beckoned by Laurence and his associates; but in Japanese there is no mention
of beckoning, and it simply says (see above).
Finally, the Lower Loran Chalice description.
The English says "there are trace remains of medical procedures in parts of Ailing Loran.
Whether these were attempts to control the scourge of the beast is unknown."
There is a significant deviation here in Japanese.
The Japanese says "were these procedures countering the beast sickness, or, priming/causing them?".
The expression used for 'priming' means literally (see above).
To me, it sounds almost as if the Pthumerian's medical procedures mirrored the
populace of Yharnam's, as they might have also discovered blood transfusion.
The Japanese questions whether they were trying to control the plague outbreak with medicine,
or causing it with medicine, like is done in Yharnam.
So, yeah, interesting stuff.
To finish up, let's rapid fire a few translations, cause they're really short and I don't need to go into too much depth.
First, "The One Reborn" translates to "The Ones Reborn".
Normally, Japanese doesn't pluralize, but the word to describe them means
'to revive/reform/reorganize a group or institution that was defunct'.
'Blood Echoes' are translated to being 'Dying Wishes of the Blood',
which reminds me of the Heir Rune which posits that the heir is a Hunter who bears the
echoing will of those before him.
Furthermore, 'Insight' is actually 'Enlightenment'.
'Frenzy' is actually 'Insanity'.
'Bloodtinge' is actually 'Blood quality'
In the Fishing Hamlet, 'The Wizened Child' is literally translated to 'The Infant Grown Old'.
Maria's weapon, 'Rakuyo', is named 'Fallen Leaf' and is referred to in the game as a fairly famous blade.
Next, the Doll knows that the Moon Presence is in the dream.
In her dialogue where she says "O flora of the moon, of the dream...",
it's clearer in Japanese that 'flora' is the name of the Moon Presence.
It's curious that she knew it existed all along.
When Micolash dies, in English he says "Now I'm waking up, I'll forget everything".
But in Japanese, he's asking a question.
He's questioning whether he'll wake up and remember anything.
In Japanese, the Celestial Dial description has a double meaning.
It says it 'will leak a secret to the user', which is another reference to the watery secret behind the clock.
In the Corruption Rune, we learn that what Alfred calls 'Vilebloods' don't refer to themselves as 'Vilebloods'.
Instead, they refer to themselves as 'The Blood Kin of Cainhurst'.
The same term is used in Annalise's lines, making it clear that Vileblood
is a slur, preferred by their Byrgenwerth rivals.
Runesmith Caryll is described with more humble language in Japanese.
He's called Copyist Caryll.
His transcription of 'beast' in English says "it is one of the first runes, and one of the first to be forbidden".
In Japanese it's said that "it is the first rune to be created and the first rune to be forbidden". No exceptions.
And finally, we start at the beginning of the game.
Remember that note that was left on the chair after your blood transfusion?
"Seek Paleblood to transcend the hunt".
In Japanese, it's actually "seek Paleblood to complete the hunt", and the Japanese reveals
that you were the one that wrote this.
It wasn't left for you by the man who did your transfusion; it was left there for you, by you.
And thanks for watching, guys.
I'm glad we could get a little bit more information out there.
Special thanks to my Pateron supporters who make this stuff possible, and I'll see you all really soon.